[Music]
hi my name's Sean tank we're here at my
restaurant in Soho in Chinese well we
know here our soup dumplings are called
Xiao long bao in China the Xiao long bao
is really it's a combination two aspects
in the dumpling Xiao Lu is what the
doubles are cooked in that's the actual
with the bamboo steamers called stylish
all along Xiao long and Chinese means
little dragon and then the bow is just a
general term for kind of a pocket of
other dumplings there are various types
of soup dumplings throughout China
there's a thicker style of skin and a
theater-style skin thicker style skin
you may recognize and it's more
predominant here in New York those tend
to be larger maybe 2-3 bite dumplings
the thinner skin double a-side be
smaller and more of a one bite dumpling
so sorry sure here's like thinner skin
smaller variety that's predominant buff
in Shanghai and in Taiwan people think
that there's a secret to our dumplings
there isn't I hate to say it's just
years of training of hard work and
knowing the proper steps to do it so the
way we make our suits on this here app
in Chinese everything is done from
scratch in the house
so every morning the chefs come in early
on to make the skin it's just water and
flour we have a machine of folds over
this game and they do that 20 to 30
times I told to my texture and the right
firmness and then they build that out
throughout the rest of the day after the
dough's been fully over by the machine
they portioned them out into individual
size just by hand
those are flattened and rolled out for
every single dumpling every day they
make broth that they then cool down and
chill in the fridge in the freezer and
then that becomes a gelatin that they
use in the soup dumpling they grind
Berkshire hog parentage pork and
aromatics including ginger
Galion and they build the soup dumpling
base and they introduced the gelatinize
pork soup or chicken soup or seafood
soup into the tsukkomi itself and then
they folded the soup dumpling therefore
the same every single time the chef's
folder in a circle counterclockwise of
our restaurants between 18 and 20 folds
the reason these don't be there fold
this way is because you actually want to
allow heat to escape the dumpling during
the cooking process
otherwise the soup could cause it to
explode
each steamer soup dumplings here is good
for about 5 minutes to 5 minutes and 30
seconds
our chefs check it throughout the
cooking process so they're looking at
every steaming to make sure that the
dumplings are kind of coming out looking
right if it looks right then probably
tastes right when people have never had
soup phones before it becomes fairly
obvious the most common mistake we see
people making agent Finley's the first
time is they try and take a half bite of
a soup dumpling there's soup in there if
you take a half by the soups going
everywhere so you know there's there's
several different ways you can eat a
soup dumpling and not burn your mouth
off
you know you grab it and you're putting
it in the spoon pinch this side with
your chopsticks to break the skin and
that great soup don't they'll be easy to
do I'm just kidding skinship you're
pretty thin and it's elastic so it won't
shatter kind of it will just break like
a piece of paper just kind of pull up
our chat leave something you can see
that the dumplings off is now soup less
and the soup isn't with a spoon and by
now it's cool enough to drink now
there's different ways to enjoy the
dumpling after that I know people who
love it with soy sauce and vinegar
me personally I just said something's by
itself just own natural all yes
so now if you bite the top off you got
this nice open dumpling the soup is
still on the inside so then you can
either pour it out into your spoon or
you can just slip it right out go back
there go the inside let your have it two
ways your soup dumpling
[Music]
you